[Música]
este fin de semana fue la Cumbre anual
de la unión africana la reunión en la
que el bloque de 55 países discutió los
temas más importantes del continente y
con la que buscó unificación frente a la
comunidad global los jefes de estado se
reunieron en la capital de Etiopía adiza
veva aunque no admitieron la presencia
de las juntas militares de Mali burkina
faso y Guinea en rechazo a los golpes de
estado que hubo en esos países para
entender Qué ocurrió en la Cumbre nos
acompaña Luis Jean Piedad quien es
doctor en ciencia política y también
autor de varios libros acerca de África
Muchas gracias Jean Pierre por estar en
directo América
Buenos días en Colombia Buenas tardes
Muchísimas gracias con ese saludo el
punto clave del encuentro Jean Pierre
fue la tolerancia cero contra los
cambios inconstitucionales de gobierno
en ese sentido el bloque de Naciones
africanas mantiene la suspensión de
burkina faso de Guinea de Mali y también
de Sudán serán efectivas estas medidas
de presión
yo creo que no porque no ha no ha dado
ningún resultado inclusive el presidente
de la comisión lo aceptó que ellos van a
estudiar esto otra vez para mirar como
ellos pueden dar una solución si no no
excluir sino
empezar un diálogo para el retorno a la
institucionalidad en esos países
mire y un tema central este año era
discutir la posibilidad de una tregua
con los yihadistas en la subregión del
sahel y el grupo Rebelde m23 en la
República democrática del Congo ahora le
pregunto si hubo avances al respecto Y
qué tantos conflictos armados están
ahora mismo desestabilizando África
el problema de
23 Es que la discusión se tiene que
hacer entre Wanda y Congo Por qué Porque
estos es los integrantes de este grupo
la mayor parte de ellos vienen de Wanda
yo creo que Kim Sasha la capital y
kingali tiene que sentarse para como
tratar de encontrar una solución a esta
situación pero no hay avance lo que está
pasando sino en a raíz de este problema
en África
encontramos que
diferentes capitales occidentales se
están explotando esta situación en
África para desplazar uno en contra a
otro por ejemplo
Moscú París Es evidente este competencia
este competición en África yo creo que
debe tener una política interna entre
ellos para resolver esta situación poner
Wanda y Congo a sentar en una mesa para
poder
encontrar una solución a esta situación
y una competencia en la que por cierto
china también es un gran actor no en
términos de infraestructura además pero
usted estaba hablando un poco de Francia
y es que estamos con la noticia en las
últimas horas de burkina faso que dio
por terminadas las operaciones de las
tropas francesas en su territorio contra
el extremismo esto Después de varios
meses de crisis de que hace un mes
Emanuel macron anunciar efectivamente el
retiro Cómo se recibió esta noticia en
la unión africana
esta esta decisión esta noticia se
decide con mucho séptica pero con qué se
van a emplazar sabemos Quién va a
reemplazar a los franceses ya se sabe
entonces
hay una septicidad en la unión sobre
todo hay países que empiezan a jugar
para como para para llenar este espacio
y sabemos sabemos muy claro que Buki y
otros países van a caer en la misma
situación pero ojo lo que debemos pensar
no es que
los actores que vienen a reemplazar
Francia baufetar algo mejor lo que pasa
es que la historia mismo dice que la
población es tan cansados con la
política occidental en estos países que
la pobreza el continente inclusive en la
en el estado de la yaspoa africana
nosotros discutimos mucho esta situación
donde occidentales solamente vienen en
África a generar más conflictos no hay
solución por ejemplo hay una cosa que
pasa Disculpe para salir un poquito del
tema hay una cosa que pasa esta semana
los la unión está pidiendo una un
asiento permanente en la ONU porque
cuando se cree la ONU muchos de esos
países africanos no eran libres entonces
todo esta situación hace que los
africanos son muy son muy descontento
con la política occidental y no
solamente busquen a faso que va a caer
otros países están en línea nunca en la
historia la cuna de la humanidad ha sido
tratada con justicia y eso hay que
decirlo vamos a hablar de otro tema que
es la gran intención de acelerar el
acuerdo del libre comercio regional y
que fue lanzado en el 2020 señor
loristón de implementarse este sería el
más grande del mundo al menos en
términos de población qué impactos
tendría para la economía africana y para
la economía global
va a haber un impacto muy positivo para
el continente por ejemplo
el cambio comercial dentro del
continente entre los países estamos
hablando Más o menos unos quince por
ciento y estamos hablando de consumidor
de mil cuatrocientos millones de
personas entonces si hacemos un una zona
comercial donde participan
extranjeros Pero yo no creo que eso va a
beneficiar a África más que los grandes
inversores occidentales de hecho el
político muy conocido de de nuestra
organización y también era Era candidato
a la presidencia de Camerún
el señor banda kanikani él ha dicho él
ha dicho que nosotros en África tiene
tenemos
implementar políticas que nos que nos
sirve a nosotros no a los grandes
inversores que vienen a aprovechar de
los consumidores y nosotros quedamos con
la pobreza Tenemos la oportunidad de una
vez por todo con la Guerra de Ucrania
Porque muchos inversores lo que han
perdido lo que han perdido en Ucrania lo
quieren reemplazar en África eso es la
intención entonces Ellos están muy
pendientes para evitar esta situación en
África bueno y siguiendo con estas
crisis del continente africano en 2012
las equilea en el cuerno de África fue
una de ellas y esta crisis de hambruna
que se disparó con el clima extremo de
allí que la seguridad alimentaria fuera
también una de las discusiones cruciales
que se esperaban en la Cumbre de la
unión africana qué fue lo que pactaron
en ese sentido
muy buena pregunta no hay una una
declaración final
de de este congreso sobre algo más allá
de la zona comercial para sacar a las
personas de la pobreza la sequía sobre
todo la sequía es un problema pero
tenemos que tener muy claro también hay
muchos países que bloquean el caudal del
río de un país a otro y eso es otra
situación que está dando mucha guerra en
África por ejemplo hay países que el río
antes de llegar a otros países lo
bloquean es una manera de hacer presión
sobre tu país o otro lo otro también de
la sequía en África yo creo que también
la innovación sobre todo una agricultura
una una cultura sostenible Hay un
problema de cambio climático también que
hay que combatir en África pero esto
todo esto hace todo un problema gigante
que necesita solución inmediata
doctor en ciencia política y autor de
libros sobre África gracias a usted por
su análisis y por compartir su
perspectiva con nosotros
gracias a nuestros televidentes les pido
que no dejen de sintonizar nos
regresamos en segundos con más directo
América
[Música]